hemos podido entrar con nuestros colegas
afganos en la pista de este aeropuerto
militar de cada uno como ven las
capturas de guerra de los nuevos amos
del país las capturas de guerra son los
helicópteros estadounidenses abandonados
hay por todos lados a mi alrededor
estamos en la pista principal la famosa
pista del aeropuerto de kabul donde han
tenido lugar estas evacuaciones
históricas durante tantos días hoy esta
pista se está totalmente vacía ya mi
alrededor no hay más que miembros de la
seguridad del taiwan's hemos caminado
dos kilómetros para entrar a través de
esta puerta norte que como vimos estaba
llena de refugiados ser candidatos al
exilio durante tantos días hoy está
totalmente controlada por el talibán hay
unas curiosas acción talibán con
equipamientos estadounidenses por todos
lados como decíamos son capturas de
guerra como estos el objetivo
no lo vemos pero nos acompañaron a esta
famosa unidad de fuerzas de seguridad
talibán que están totalmente equipadas
uniforme y material estadounidense así
como vehículos blindados todo esto dice
mucho sobre la debacle del ejército
jordano durante estas semanas de
ofensiva del grupo talión que hoy ya es
el amo del país pero también el hecho
que la propaganda talibán hoy en día es
como nos confirmó sabi su la moda el
portavoz del grupo talibán hemos vencido
el mayor ejército del mundo el
estadounidense los estadounidenses se
han ido a la ocupación es sólo producto
de sabor y ya que por otro lado en el
plano simbólico hace unas horas cuando
todavía era de noche los últimos
miembros del comando de la fuerza delta
evacuaron en el último avión militar
estadounidense se dice que dos miembros
de este comando de la mano habilitantes
talibán que tomaron posesión en medio de
la noche antes de lo previsto en esta
pista del aeropuerto militar de kabul
kabul se despierto y bajo el emirato
islámico de afganistán controlada por el
talibán ellos están al mando
intentan mostrarnos esta es la razón por
la que me voy a ir al aeropuerto quieren
mostrarnos que tienen el control sobre
todo la seguridad porque su prioridad es
la
desesperada hay un importante riesgo y
atentado esta mañana el grupo estado
islámico de sant y están la rama en asia
central del grupo estado islámico el
gran rival aquí el talibán ellos quieren
recordar su capacidad de perjudicar y
sobre todo de desestabilizar la
seguridad del grupo talibán esto es un
atentado a 500 metros de aquí sobre la
vid gate hace cuatro días un atentado
que causó más de 200 muertos y también
de tiros de cohetes constantemente que
hasta ahora como ayer por la mañana
fueron interceptados por el sistema
antimisiles estadounidense evidentemente
entre enemigos no se hacen regalos
el sistema fue desconectado ya no hay
más protección sólo están los talibán
para asegurar el aeropuerto afganistán y
cada uno que persiste es temido de un
ataque del estado islámico cuyos
militantes siguen en la ciudad
mismo tiempo